[Music]
[Music]
oh
subject for today
[Music]
[Applause]
oh what a delicious beverage yeah i'm
not gonna be doing santa the whole day
but as you can see
i've got everything going on the dye the
beard uh we'll be talk
we're gonna get to this pretty quickly i
will be interviewing the kid
from the mall yesterday uh um you know
that that cami santa tried to ruin
christmas by telling him that he
wouldn't give him a nerf gun so
today on the show we have the mom which
name sabella
i don't remember his son's name is
michael yeah and uh he's going to get a
cornucopia
of firearm related toys activities
and just general trinkets tchotchkes
because santa
folks in case you know santa casey
unless you thought that
i had forgotten because of my uh because
of my outfit
yeah strapped too oh
yeah they're what
so you know it's a little bit tough it's
tough for me to move in with my gut here
yeah
what are you in detroit but we'll be
talking about that yeah we're talking
about the pope who uh i believe is a
communist
and he can go to hell apparently from
what i'm seeing he might now listen
plan it on great catholics out there i
understand a lot of catholics are upset
with this pope
just this pope if only he spent as much
time preaching the message of salvation
as he does
uh the karl marx manifesto yeah so we'll
be talking about that we'll be talking
about elon omar who uh sleeps with her
brother
and uh allegedly a lot to get to
this is you know what though this is it
broke my heart for people who have not
seen that video yet uh and everyone
watching by the way right now the
the fastest thing you can do to help
this video is comment do it just comment
just leave a comment what do you think
did you want toy guns as a kid did your
parents let you have nerf guns did they
let you have super soakers and were
doing ask me anything next week with an
ultra long stream so anything you want
to ask
we'll have like nine hours on the road
i'll explain that in a little bit oh
lord
uh so for those who have not seen this
you're saying why are you doing this why
aren't you talking about well listen i
think we've done a pretty good job of
covering the election fraud
yeah yeah we haven't backed it down no
it's a bunch of it
and this is something that also matters
because christmas is important christmas
is a really
valuable time to teach kids about
morality and
and more importantly that guns are not
immoral objects that firearms can be
used to actually protect people i guess
i should say first and third chair audio
eight is here
uh my quarter black elf is here he's
accepted not the north pole nor the
south
i'm jolly and gerald a how are you i'm
i'm well i'm not yeah you don't have a
great peripheral vision weird yeah i
don't know what to do today and we also
have joe lewis right there who's
curled up somewhere uh oh by the fire
with
care don't put your hands near his mouth
unless you want to lose them
oh wow his chestnuts are roasting let's
start with this this is for people who
missed it this happened yesterday and
you know what it's my show
so every now and then i'm going to take
the floor to talk about something that
bothers me i love
christmas i get christmas lights up
before thanksgiving i catch flak fort
i don't care you know what you have a
problem with joy
fine it's my true it's not even my truth
it's my joy
and i think santa has done me good will
do me good and i say
god bless him and when a lower level
fight for 15 mall store communist tries
to ruin christmas for a little boy
well you know what we raise money for
david dorn we raise money for hurricane
harvey
and by god i want to make this little
boy's christmas so let's start off for
people who missed it
uh and we'll come back to this commie
santa
i warn you it might break your heart
what do you want for christmas
what's a nerf gun no guns
nope not even a nerf gun
nope if your dad wants to get it for you
that's fine but i can't bring it to you
but what else would you like
lots of other toys there's legos
bicycles
cars and trucks what do you think
what do you think scolding the kit what
do you think
it's okay if you're dead oh my god oh my
gosh
what a prick yeah what a pr you know
what santa
santa you deserve to be pulled aside by
daddy and get a nice little merry ass
whooping
this is just and you know what's so
wrong the kid who by the way is four
years old four years old he looks tall
for a four-year-old i was like six or
seven
for a four-year-old kid he held it
together yeah he held it together until
the santa wanted to scold him with his
agenda no no what else
i said what else really how about you
come over here and sit on my
knee let me bend you over it and uh it's
gonna be a little bit more than a
spanking you're gonna find more than a
lump of coal in your stocking santa
you know what yeah you're never going to
stop young boys from wanting firearms
and by the way
let me show you some pictures there's a
long and storied history of santa claus
with guns here you go look there's
shanna's gone to war world war
ii i can't see if that's an m1 rifle i'm
not exactly sure
show up show some more pictures there
you got santa with a gun
let's show another picture there you go
but there we have a positive collage of
santa with the gun
because for the longest time in this
country we understood
that guns weren't in they were an
inanimate object
it's a rich and storied part of our
history i'm i was raised in canada where
nobody i ever knew had a handgun except
for one guy who had a war relic in the
magical closet of mystery
which was very dangerous because the
kids showed it to me when his dad wasn't
around and we had no respect for
it whatsoever that gun was so old hadn't
been oiled that bullet would probably
hit you sideways first but the point
remains kids used to ask for bb guns
yeah you know what you're never going to
stop boys from wanting guns or knives do
you know why
women you may not understand it's not
just feminists it's the feminization
of young boys because young boys you
know they're powerless
there's a four-year-old boy is powerless
he's weak everyone's bigger
everyone's stronger everything's scary
the world's a big place everything is up
and you're down and you know what that's
why they take an interest
in things like swiss army knives and
guns and power tools
and wood burning sets which that is
absolute fire hazard
the reason for it is because they want
to have some semblance of power and it's
a wonderful
teaching opportunity to teach your young
men
how to bridle that power how to use that
power to protect the vulnerable
how to use power and wield it for good
kind of like weighted using firearms to
free the slaves
but instead because moms go oh no no no
no no i don't like guns you don't give
that boy any experience with anything
powerful
he never learns how to respect it or
handle it and what happens you raise a
bully because the second
they get a little bit of power they
wield it over anyone
weaker than them how many bullies do you
think had parents who took them through
proper
firearm safety training with their red
rider
yeah the left wing looks at those old
images of santa holding the gun and says
remember back in the day before we
learned that guns hurt
right yeah it's like people weren't
stupid they knew that there were certain
uses for them that were good and certain
uses that weren't
but you could still like yeah it's
almost like that's the reason the
peacemaker was invented by good old
names samuel
it's the great equalizer you stupid
commie bastard
and by the way is maul santa doing your
job there when mom steps in and says no
no no it's it's just a nerf gun you
ought to take a cue
you ought to take a cue and go oh a nerf
gun oh
fantastic little johnny whatever right
you just move on you know what if you're
if you're a coward and you're terrified
of nerf guns
just say nothing about you right now
they were they were they were coached to
say oh well you know we'll see what
happens
you're a good little boy because you
don't know the parent's budget
yeah when i was a kid i went to santa
claus i went to santa claus and i
already had a mask and snorkel set
and i said uh i was three years old
right i think we might even have this on
instagram
oh by the way where i think you guys can
uh follow me i don't know what we have
here what we're talking about
well you can follow me on parlor we put
up videos where i went to santa
and i said uh i want uh a scuba diving
set he's like oh
oh a mask don't finish that phrase santa
i don't want a mask and snorkel
i already have them and water always
gets in because it's not really a
silicon
seal they're not really fitting it to my
chrome structure to my cranium structure
at kb what i want is the ability to
breathe under water santa
i want a tank i want a pressurized tank
i asked for it and there is a video of
me opening up
an under a mask and snorkel set in me
going where's my tank
that's why promise didn't work wow
that's why santa doesn't promise it
well i'll tell you what they don't coach
you to do is say no yeah
yeah what's especially no yeah it just
blows me away
he didn't ask for a porno mag he didn't
ask her to stick a dynamite in a match
like he said
nerf gun and his mom steps into hell
what are you doing like if you have some
moral problem with it you just say like
oh oh wow
what else yeah right it's very easy you
want a nerf gun
oh oh how about a nice little
non-disclosure
aids law regulator does that fit the
bill
you can lobby your local representative
at the wholesome street fair
how about hormone blockers from saturn
nerf gun how about some nice estrogen
pills
i don't want you to get hurt you
wouldn't want to happen i don't know
that wouldn't want this removed from you
so we're going to have that mom on later
to tell the story by the way that kid
also wants to be like dad because his
dad is a cop
oh that's awesome which also is a great
twist yeah yeah
you need a [ __ ] no i don't say no
not at all there's not a court in the
world that's going to
blame me for roughing you up santa's
going to find some parking tickets
on his car
[Laughter]
so we're going to have the mom on and
the boy on and uh hopefully i've got
some information here for people uh who
we have some information a little boy
and give him a little bit of magic of
christmas
good this is the beauty of mug club
because we're able to give back do
consider joining up at livecrotter.com
club crowder election stream is still
the pro homo code
it's never gonna get old because the
election has not been called
um and of course you can follow me on
parlor because facebook isn't being very
nice with us okay
jerks what else we have a lot to get to
before we have the mom and the boy on
for the interview
uh ted cruz senator ted cruz this is
something people haven't been talking
about this is big news yeah
he's going to present the oral arguments
if the supreme court takes up the
lawsuit uh seeking to obviously we know
overturn the the 2020 presidential
election here's a clip
texas senator ted cruz telling fox news
exclusively quote
petitioners legal team has asked me
whether i would be willing to argue the
case before the supreme court if the
court grant certiorari
i have agreed and told them that if the
court takes the appeal
i will stand ready to present the oral
argument
oh good for senator ted cruz yeah i like
it he's not a guy you want uh
one on your tail no
he's presented in front of the supreme
court many many many times
so he'd be the perfect candidate also
keep in mind that we are not past the 37
days
i guess it's not even a deadline but 37
days that it took for the al gore
florida debacle to reach the supreme
court yeah
yeah should get there fast yeah and it's
like
if everybody who's talking about voter
fraud is a conspiracy theorist is ted
cruz a conspiracy theorist for wanting
to talk to the supreme court i think
he's
he seems to have a pretty high standard
for what evidence is and what truth is
no oh sorry he's a crackpot pretty much
i think ted cruz
is uh he's been looking at too many home
alone two covers oh
white supremacist not many white
supremacists with the last name cruz by
the way
if you're mad about ted cruz's photo
from going hunting
shoot yourself um with what
the nerf gun you did you i don't know
what listen i'm not going to go
borrow it anyone who gets mad
this is so s i thought we were beyond
this i've never hunted but if you want
to know the people who do more for
conservationism than anyone else
it's it's hunters okay yeah it's hunters
they go out there that animal at least
you know that it died it
died a humane death you any idea what
halal is
oh
if i could sit a deer down right now one
of the reindeer and say listen
would you rather be taken out by a would
you rather be taken out by a 30 odd six
and be gone before you know it which i
think all of us would want that right
either go in your sleep or just be
hunted without knowing it
or would you like would you like some
imam to slice your throat
i mean if you guys look up and i don't
have a problem with people doing their
halal thing listen
cultural it's like kosher my primary
problem is the bombs
ah don't no let's not bring up hold on
it's fair
put that down no yeah my face is very
sticky
uh right now everything is oh really
yeah it's really this is you know i
didn't want to do the fake stuff i
wanted to
bring the kid the magic of christmas
looks like candy canes you're eating
okay
uh something else by the way um this has
been going on in michigan and i just
watched this segment this morning on cnn
and it is everything wrong with the
media and how they are covering people
who understand their constitutional
liberties right now
i think we have the first clip right the
first clip there were people in michigan
who were petitioning uh the secretary of
state to stop the steel
this is the riot that
[Applause]
the ensued we won't allow them to steal
this freedoms and you must
turn yourself
i think she was looking up how to build
a pipe bomb
[Laughter]
she's like how do you riot so this is
what spur yeah siri
i'm sorry i don't recognize the white
voice software
do you mean peaceful protest yeah did
you are you antifa
no i can't help you
[Laughter]
so this brought up the michigan uh
attorney general who was talking about
this on cnn yeah
and uh talk about gaslighting where they
just say no evidence there was a segment
called uh reality check
oh i hate that they said there's no
evidence they uh claim that this video
in georgia shows people uh
continuing counting though it's been
debunked i'm like well where's the
reality i thought i was gonna check my
reality
yeah so um then the michigan uh
attorney general her name is dana nessel
dana nacelle um
not a fan this is the segment that went
on and i'll just offer some commentary
as this happened this was at i think 6
55 this morning
you've said when you saw this that this
is not activism
this is terrorizing and so legally
speaking
what can be done how do we stop the
first amendment well look people have
a right to uh you know make their
grievances known under the first
amendment
good but there is a time and a place and
a manner
and had they wanted to uh demonstrate or
protest outside of her offices
and pulled the proper permits to do so
that would have been absolutely fine
but instead they chose to disrupt the
peace and tranquility of a neighborhood
under the cover of
darkness uh and the cover of darkness
comes in handy when you're burning down
the right
first amendment you cannot trespass you
cannot threaten people
uh you cannot disrupt um you know
noise ordinances or engage in disorderly
conduct
and call it protected first amendment
activity
we're going to be on the lookout for
this kind of behavior and are you
encourage police when they arrive on the
scene to start issuing tickets and
potentially arresting people in the
event that they are committing
crimes and as state attorney general uh
i intend to vigorously prosecute
now the first off as far as intending to
vigorously prosecute she said
the first amendment doesn't protect
crimes uh she has not from what i've
seen there's no record of her
prosecuting any of the black lives
matter
protesters or antifa protesters who by
the way across the country have
committed billions of dollars in damages
wow
dozens of fatalities thousands of
injuries
uh nothing at all but when people have
some signs and some bull horns
apparently well now you need a perm oh
like there's someone there from antifun
black lives matter going
a permit yeah i am so
let me call my i am so sorry that i
burned down
a five below exactly my bad
now i know now i know no listen
yes you guys did nothing you guys did
nothing for months as american cities
burned you couldn't care less and now
you're mad that they're doing it it is a
residential area what about the
mcclassicals
not only do they go in the residential
area they brought they went through a
fence they run private property
and you charge the people in their own
house
just for showing their firearm
collection
yeah as soon as it's in people with
trump flags though lady voldemort has a
problem with it yes
yeah yes i expected in that interview
her to just answer
don't speak her name and by the way just
to give you an idea while she's talking
about this now she's playing tough uh
when trump offered to send in the
national guard to help with the protest
right now
this lady female voldemort responded she
said president trump's politically
motivated threat to send more federal
law enforcement to detroit among other
cities has nothing to do with protecting
public health or safety it is about
using the power of his office as a
cudgel to punish those
who use their constitutionally
guaranteed rights to express views
he disagrees with uh in contrast with
arresting people for
signs ah interesting signs friggin
cuddles
by the way don't you know in rules for
radical page one step one
pull the permit yeah to be able to
protest right that was exactly what
people were told to do right
he's known for his permit yeah permits
to protest
these people say get a permit well who
issues the permits i do
what's the likelihood of them very very
slim oh you want to protest me the
person who
actually department they're not going to
do it what does that even mean
yeah yeah it's insanity in grand rapids
alone it was over 500 000
in overtime just the overtime for the
police force and by the way those are
the same people that are probably
complaining right now that there's not
like a relief package for all the
businesses that are closed
i don't know there was 500 000 that we
could have spent on it but we had to do
it for the police
ironic for people who want to defund the
police here
time and a half yeah yeah you're doing
great for them they're making lots of
everything
that the left espouses right now is
wrong
oh everything i touch turns to ruins you
are such a blockhead current democratic
party
santa claus communists pope communists
who are about to get into vaccines
they want to infringe on your first
amendment rights talk about gas every
american's going well hold on a second i
looked out my window
and it was like skynet had fallen and
now
because someone has a sign and a bull
horn i get it it would be nicer if they
did it at the office as opposed to a
residential area but you know what they
probably don't issue permits
they won't they will kick you off
[Music]
let me ask you this before we go on we
have some news with the vaccine what's
your opinion on the covid vaccine again
best thing you can do to help with this
this episode is just comment leave
yourself a comment um any comment will
do do you think
that the vaccine is going to end the
pandemic do you plan on taking it why or
why not or are you like
uh the anti-vaxxers the vax deniers
cuomo
harris and company yes yes
so uh oh no wait before that before that
um i think we need to uh cover this
while we're talking about the vaccine in
kovid
um this is one of my this is not my joke
but one of my favorite jokes from uh
i don't remember who told it yeah could
have been nicked apollo could have been
i have no idea safe bet to just say if
it's funny nick apollo
yeah how do you know if someone is a
nurse or a teacher
they tell you and okay this lady right
here
the one in charge of your children's
education
uh is reacting to anti-lock down by the
way i guess people in line with the
world health organization
anti-lock down protesters so here's a
lady
who screams at them see if you can spot
her chosen profession
kill yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
now look
she looks around to make sure everyone
hears her
no doubt in the real heroics
that was actually that clip was brought
to you by the home school association of
america
yeah yeah yeah local private schools
do you want to send your kids to this
you're calling our school's
indoctrination
i teach kids right really
between bouts of screaming yeah i love
you
you accuse chestnuts of being lazy do
you scream at the cat because it didn't
vote
you crazy [ __ ] so yeah i hope they're
as persua
her students are as persuasive as yes
how does that jive with your school's
zero tolerance policy yeah
she teaches logic actually in the debate
yeah love how she's so
mad that she loses all control of how to
operate a vehicle and her wipers are
just going and she can't turn them off
come on don't get sexy well at least she
was wearing a mask on her chin
yes i'm so thankful more disease that's
true so considerable not by the insanity
of my chili chit chat
kelly ourself i'm like oh wow what is
she teaching what does she think she's
proving by saying i'm a teacher
well she looked around to make sure that
everybody knew it okay so it's just
f you i'm a teacher i don't know it was
killing yourself
that's the structure out of my car let
me take an unpopular viewpoint sure sure
yeah everyone is saying that teachers
are heroes no
um
that was the end of star if statement
yeah sorry full stop
generally heroes don't have time to
full-time upload tick-tock videos
teachers and nurses imagine that in
d-day yeah
what is santa's opinion on teachers does
santa love teachers or well i think some
of them
help are young and some of them are
horrible [ __ ]
male and female well if a male
goes into the teaching profession
outside of university
i don't need to spell that one out for
you there oh wow
oh lot of chimney crawling
sweeping professions that don't exist
anymore
that's true very true hi listen if you
want to be
if you want to be a teacher a full-time
teacher might i suggest
blacksmithing or serving your country so
here's the thing i want to be clear
about she said we'll go to the recess my
family
my fam students families are dying fact
check
false or cnn would say reality check
[Laughter]
it's perfectly reasonable now wherever
you line up on vaccines it is perfect
and i'm not an anti-vaxxer at all
right polio what is it mumps measles
shingles whatever i don't know which one
i'm taking the vaccines okay
but it is perfectly reasonable at this
point in time
for a young person as we talk about
vaccines to
reject a vaccine why because people
understand this with this vaccine it's a
two-course vaccine yeah okay i didn't
know and they have to specifically coach
doctors
right now on the two-course vaccine
uh to get people to stay with the second
course because the first course
is so wildly unpleasant they've
described it like a hangover from health
splitting headache
chills you know feeling fever fevery
body ache that people won't come back
for the second course
yeah so right now they have to spend
time right in orientation with doctors
saying
people are going it's way worse than
most vaccines and it's particularly bad
for young people
people who often are not affected by the
disease nearly as seriously
so to not get sick you have to get
extremely sick
right and you might not even get sick in
the first place right exactly
right especially by the way the research
from the clinical symptoms they manifest
in only 21
of infections from 10 to 19. that means
that 79
of middle schoolers they have no
symptoms of covid
and then most of the remaining are very
mild symptoms so
when you compare that with feeling like
uh with feeling like cameron and ferris
bueller for
three and a half days it's reasonable
for some people to say you know what
okay i'll leave the vaccine for the
vulnerable and
maybe i don't have a week to take off
work i know you think that people can
take off work indefinitely and there's a
never-ending pile of money from scoot
scrooge mcduck's mansion but that's how
it works that's just for teachers yeah
it is clear the left doesn't want
anybody to be able to make a decision
for themselves
to be able to weigh the risks of certain
behaviors right they have to take away
the consequences of your actions even if
they
even if their evaluation of the
situation is totally backwards well yeah
so i i should have
prefaced this uh but england in the uk
they're gonna the first vaccine was
administered
oh really so everyone's great listen
good they want to take the vaccine great
and i think that i think that many
people
should use the vaccine yeah but to act
as though someone in this scenario might
feel uncomfortable particularly a young
person
understanding the side effects uh might
opt to not take the vaccine
that they're a crazy anti-vaxxer that's
just unreasonable and not fair
and what if they use the same reasons
that the left has used before where
they're like well i don't really
trust donald trump's administration to
be able to coordinate this and i
don't think that it should have been
rushed by trump or by all of this sort
of problem what if
what if that's their reason can they
then are they
now they're complaining donald trump
didn't order more pfizer vaccines
which by the way was because of
competition in other companies bringing
more vaccines to market that didn't want
to just order all of them from pfizer so
let's
that's fake news i won't even spend any
time on it but you guys said you didn't
want any vaccines
if it came from the trump administration
so you can go fornicate yourself with a
wire brush
before we continue we have so much to
get to today why the pope is a communist
and i'm really looking forward to
interviewing this young man
yeah uh you can tweet out santa pack
seat tweet that out hashtag santa pax
heat because uh people are gonna be mad
um we have to go oh don't we have uh we
have actually uh to check in with our
los angeles traffic report it's a
contractual obligation
uh los angeles traffic this morning uh
with thomas finnegan on the ground
mr finnegan what do you got for us sir
morning steven
uh i'm here on the 405 and uh
um i guess
thomas can you hear us tom tom
oh did the call
we'll check back in with him later yeah
yeah an
itchy ear canal because of all the uh
dye
yeah you know if traffic wasn't bad
before it is now yeah well actually i
think the 405 is completely empty right
now because no one's going to jobs
that was really more of a byproduct of
the big gulp
you got to ban it looks like found the
other car yeah yeah the one other car
was the road
um all right let's move on so pete this
isn't really a huge story but it is just
one of those that uh
should piss off all the right people and
sometimes people say why do you only
talk about things that piss you off
i don't only talk about things that piss
me off we're about to give a multi
thousand dollar gift of nerf guns to a
kid so i think we do good where we can
but sometimes i'm a negative nancy
oh there's a lot of pisses of something
you're such a negative name that's not
an
it's not an invalid criticism
i accept it so pete davidson was on
snl mocking and keep in mind too as they
mock down in the united states this is a
perfect example of where things
things that shouldn't be political now
i'm not a centrist and i've been very
clear when people say this is prop it's
not propaganda
because i let you know that i am to the
right of center in many ways to the
right of attila the hun okay
just to be very clear but all of our
sources from this show that are
available if you
click the link in the description
loudcrater.com i try to make it
available for you so you can make your
own decisions i understand that people
are in echo chambers
okay that being said um
it's not political being anti-lockdown
the world health organization said that
lockdowns don't work that should be a
last resort good example of this when i
was in canada i was in quebec where we
had liberals and liberal separatists
um the conservative wing of the canadian
political uh
political spectrum a parliamentary
system which is broken when people say
two party system man i go you can have a
prime minister elected with a minority
of the vote so
trust me it's not a flawless system but
it's better than what they have in old
europe and in canada
with the queen still on our money um
they didn't have the housing
crash in canada so even though they're
all liberal and they have like a 50
something percent tax rate and you have
socialized health care and you have a 15
sales tax when this was brought to the
attention of canadians they said yeah
we're gonna we're gonna give people
loans
and uh you know mortgages with crazy low
interest and people who can't afford to
pay it back these are all the liberals
and candidates
that's [ __ ] it's not political they
said no
just like the world health organization
said no you can't just do lockdowns
because it's not political but in the
united states it has been turned into
if you oppose lockdowns that end
livelihoods forevermore
uh you must be a rube and an anti-vaxxer
like a chris cuomo here is pete davidson
the only name i recognize at snl
um uh mocking his fellow countrymen i
take it that you found these protests
frustrating
yeah man they're making us look like
babies you know you know it's bad
when even people in boston are like ah
drink it home your quiz
that's funny and do you think that
people should stay at home until the
pandemic gets better
yeah everyone wants to go have fun but
there's plenty of stuff you could do at
home like use your official pete
davidson vibrator
that's a sexual joke that's a little bit
they get a little bit blue
by the way just so you know pete
davidson still has a job and uh he's
being paid 15 000 an episode
which sounds like a lot but i actually
know that's very
snl is hurting because i know quite a
few snl cast members from back in the
day of
uh the dennis miller era the norm era
the spade era
and uh they were starting at salaries
higher than that and pete davidson's
been there for what five six years
yeah yeah he is one of the only
recognizable names from the cast
they can't they can't procure the talent
no well and i'm surprised they allowed
him to say
the q word that's weird which word
uh we can't say it uh no no it's in the
lgbtq oh yeah yeah but you can't like
call people back in front of it oh no
you can't you can drink at home no no
you don't you don't understand
he's half black so the question the
question is
just like i can say it because i have a
cousin who's gay that's why i can't
by the way hit the notification bell if
you are subscribed on youtube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
we stream in the mornings 10 a.m eastern
week days
um so much streaming yes a lot of
streaming
frothy stop it stop i knew it
so you think people should stay home
until the pandemic gets better
it is better yeah we're there better
than when
what is the standard again that's that
we have more hospitalizations
maybe than we did stop stop stop
everyone stop you've lost
you've you've lost the plo sick people
are going to hospitals
don't think that's who pat benatar was
singing about sweetheart no
i thought she had some points i don't
know and to add to the hypocrites by the
way snl this is something a lot of
people don't know we talked about this
yesterday where they
banned outdoor dining but then they had
the the craft services table
um snl used a lockdown loophole to get
around the prohibitions on indoor
gatherings so that they could film the
show
here's the thing they were allowed to
have an indoor audience oh right right
really because they paid the audience
member uh
members as employees which they kind of
are because i have to follow
instructions
yeah this is like the reductio of like
well yeah of course oh so now they're
paying people to laugh
it's not it's not just that they're
holding up the signs well they tried
asking them to laugh originally and it
just wasn't that didn't work
think about it when you're seeing snl
and you're seeing them bomb that's with
a crowd animator going
and they have money in their pockets yes
from the show
that is insane they've gone through a
lot of crowd animators they uh they seem
to drink themselves into an early grave
so yeah stuff they go through crowd
animators faster than shapiro go through
secretaries now i don't mean anything on
tour i just mean that
he has high standards ah there we go yes
right of course listen we all know the
excel sheet and
the formatting sheet and then you're
fired
that's always what happens it's always
the exercise if you're gonna go work for
benjamin shapiro
yes get your excel get your spreadsheets
right
uh and this is just again when people
wonder how donald trump won both times
um it's because of this elitism
it really is you have a guy who is
employed and he can make it work through
a loophole and you see this in
california
and so now let's go to a response from
one of the actual
uh citizens who suffer under these
lockdowns
who don't make 15 000 an episode like
pete davidson
in uh the great city of okay the city of
new york the place
the ignorance level is so high now that
you have mega millionaires
who are on the national spotlight like
the folks on saturday night live
um and instead of making fun of their
friends
and the local business owners who are
broke and crushed
and bankrupt instead of coming down here
as fellow staten islanders and standing
up for them and bringing a positive
right
what they want to do is go on national
tv and try to humiliate the little man
when he's down
and to me that's quite disgusting if you
came out of your perch
in your affluent neighborhood came down
here and told the liberal left this is a
good thing because it's about our
freedom and liberty
we probably wouldn't be standing here
today talking about a political prisoner
who was the victim of
in my view a political ambush and by the
way only black people can say that mark
lamont hill once said that all
prisoners were political prisoners and
got into trouble for that because of
this idea of mass incarceration take it
up with harris sweetheart your
vice president-elect i say that
facetiously yeah um
this is what i love he's like they're on
their perch
yeah they're on their perspective on
their birthday full of [ __ ] you can't
read the newspaper
under their perch i look down
what's black white red all over and
covered in your [ __ ]
it's you from your perch pete davidson
that guy's like a caricature of a
mobster
yeah exactly and it was really funny
that he said that while he was doing the
exact opposite of his advice
but they're like oh what can people do
and it's bad well they could stay home
there's plenty
are you home you're out working you're
here
yeah this is the compassionate left yeah
this is this is the guy who
yeah their their vision of themselves is
being very compassionate is because
they don't actually talk to people who
are hurting yeah they're just told who
to feel bad for and who not to feel bad
for
they pick and choose or people who are
employing you know uh where
schumer and uh now they're saying he
might just whoa with a wave of a pen
you know 50 000 student loans forgiven
you know here's the thing
you are compassionate only to the lowest
common denominator the people who took
out loans for underwater basket weaving
or afro-lesbian
feminist studies uh you know who's going
to be mad about that people
who paid off their loans yeah people who
opted
not to go to university or go to a
community college or go to a trade
school
just like what they say oh you know what
the rich should pay more uh in taxes
listen if biden has his way with taxes
depending on the plan
you can take two or three salaries from
this company boom cut it off the top
because this is this is not a small
business mind you according to the box
uh
biden tax bracket course it's 12 once
you're you're we're about 12 to 12 to 15
employees i think we have some
contractors i think we have 14 employees
so we're we're just like walt we need to
be treated like the walton family
good night economy good night sam that's
where we are
they're compassionate they're
compassionate to the zeroes to the
non-contributors
who think that it is empathetic for them
to be able to stay home indefinitely
while the people who keep our economy
alive
take it on the chin because i'm a
teacher
exactly those are the people they're
gonna go after and help the people that
are screeching i have a friend from
church in canada who's a teacher and all
he does is post on social media about
like i had to clean my desks and i
wasn't paid for overtime
and it's like oh oh the horror the
horror
i thought you were doing it because he
cared about the kids oh
all of a sudden little clorox is beyond
your purview
right that's when that's when it's time
for uh raises and negotiations put some
purell on your desk next to the apples
and call it a day
um are you saying that we have uh who do
we have uh do we we have a sabella
michael oh
well um can well they're both there
right now
uh michael's senior the dad oh michael
senior can we can we go to them in a
little bit because i think we still have
a couple more things to get to if they
can just hold for about 10 minutes
okay okay just 10 minutes i really want
to make sure that we get that correct
and i also know
uh that i think we have someone else who
might be checking in with us so um
let's move here on to the pope uh really
quickly uh and then we'll keep cycling
along through this
um earmuffs on this one
yeah i don't make sure that make sure
that young michael isn't there because i
need to get into sarah
i need to get into santa character um
and we do need to check in with finnegan
i do want to see
yeah yeah somebody should go ahead i'm
worried so in his new book the head of
the 1.5 billion dollar church the pope
uh with 22 amazon reviews so things are
looking up
he criticized liberty-minded
conservatives now let's keep in mind
that this pope has said that christians
should never seek to convert unbelievers
and that tax cuts are a sin if the
wealthy get them
and he compared trump's immigration
policies to king herod's massacre of
children
so he's no stranger to rhetoric yeah
that's what donald trump said
listen listen i want you to find
every first firstborn
attacks the hell i don't know if we can
i don't know if we can don't tax them i
don't want to tax them you want to kill
them no
i support the life of the unborn and
after they're born what do you want the
census to be
i just want to make sure they're doing
okay
i want to give them more money bring me
the christ
what a monster so here's some here are
some direct quotes from the po
the the the infallible dumbass and chief
and i want to know
catholics out there listen this is not
about there have been a lot of popes who
i've liked right yeah
not this guy leave your comments a lot
of the best thing you can do to help
the show they have a here's a quote from
the pope
some groups protested refusing to keep
their distance marching against travel
restrictions and he writes this as if
measures that governments must impose
for the good of their people
constitute some kind of political
assault on autonomy or personal freedom
yes yes yes a little bit answer
that's your argument i'll let me make a
counter argument
that's what lawyers i'm a lawyer call a
counter argument yes it is an assault on
personal autonomy and by the way just
saying
as though some sort of government
regulations for the common good
makes it inherently virtuous every
single government overreach every single
act of tyranny was done for the common
good
from taxation without representation to
let's go right through it
stalin okay some of the worst atrocities
here's this is a writing from stalin
stalin didn't say here's what we are
going to do is we're going to take over
farms and then no one will have food
so that we have no base for economy
that's not what we planned
we want them to feel bad yes and they
will look
away when we take your women they always
look away
here's what he said we did not build
this society in order to
restrict personal liberty oh that's nice
but in
order that the human individual may feel
really free
it is difficult for me to imagine what
personal liberty is enjoyed by an
unemployed person who goes about hungry
and cannot find employment real liberty
can exist
only where exploitation has been
abolished unless it's coming from the
state yeah
where no one has a where there is no one
no
oppression of some by others unless of
course you're talking about 20 something
million dead
where there is no unemployment in
poverty that worked like a charm
where a man is not haunted by the fear
of tomorrow being deprived of
work of home and of bread not only were
they deprived of work home and bread
they couldn't even find the wheat or the
yeast
to make the bread your hipsters with
your stupid yeast starters i don't know
when that became a trend but you would
have had that under stalin
so if according to the postwar the pope
we're supposed to
take everybody at their word we're
supposed to to evaluate policies by
their stated
motives right and not by their
consequences that very short-term
thinking and
it's not how adults think you know what
surprised me 51
of those riskies today admire stalin wow
he's got staying helmet what 51 yeah
they might
maybe they just don't realize what
happened maybe they outlawed teaching
history
in russia they don't have the heroes
they don't support you know what they
don't have they don't have the teachers
screaming in their cars
they don't they just they they usually
kill them first hey let's go to mao
pope mao killed tens of millions of
people for the good of the people there
are some
you know basically make pilgrimages when
people try and go and you know visit
mao land sites and here's actually an
article from the guardian uh where it
says shedding tears as he saw
mao's rubbery cadaver up close for the
first time hwang told the newspaper
our generation has a very deep
attachment to mao who created a
harmonious society
in which people could trust each other
with no tricks at all
that's by the way when you have someone
saying like it's a great society with
no tricks now means there's probably
some tricks yeah don't look here
the tens of millions of people would
like to have a word with you about how
great that society was how great that
leap forward was
city rabbit tricks are for westerners by
the way
i watched the trix rabbit go in and
purchase his own box of tricks get
mugged by
kids this is the problem with
entitlement in the united
handle states the rabbit just wants some
tricks he really well i don't know if
there's a gesture tracked four tricks
but the point is
freedom for me not for thee that's what
those kids say here's another pope
claim this is this is a quote directly
from his book 22 reviews
you'll never find such people protesting
the death of george floyd
okay that's loaded but let's continue or
joining a demonstration because there
are shanty towns where children lack
water education
or because there are whole families who
have lost their income wait a second
the communist pope is saying that you
will not find these people who are
anti-lockdown
protesting families who've lost their
income
that's the whole reason both the world
health organization
and liberty-minded individuals in the
united states
are protesting lockdowns don't take my
word for it
we have 1500 over 1500 staten island is
protesting tonight
there's probably a thousand left and we
are peacefully protesting
no rioting no looting
wow
[Applause]
what were they saying were they saying
uh are they saying uh kill people
yeah do you see that were they saying
get the uden
yeah i think they said something about
open up business so they
yeah could help people who lost their
income you're missing the scary american
flags
stephen that was really symbolic yeah
that's really scary unless you're a
country
who is under tyrannical rule and you're
the only thing you're hoping for seeing
over that hill
is the american flag and the sounds of
our scary black rifles
that's true is the assumption here that
nobody on the left wants to open
businesses
that none of these business owners could
be on the left many of them are they
live in los angeles it's a very blue
place
so i they're again the pope's saying
that you won't see the same people
open protesting business closes as you
would maybe a george floyd protest or
something
maybe they are yeah like all you have to
do is one person and then his entire
argument falls apart
well i think this is again they're
tipping their hand he's like yeah we
don't see these people uh
uh uh because we want we don't want to
open businesses oh
that's the problem that's the problem
right here is you don't want to open
businesses
stop it i'm stop it i must go think of
holy things and
yeah exactly the assumption is that
business is inherently
some kind of negative thing it's some
it's like
these are all again marxist communist
assumptions yeah that the
pope just gets to go get away with
here's another one he says in his 22
time review book that uh restrictions
necessary that these people think
restrictions necessary for people's
protections amount to an unjust demand
of an interfering state there are
politicians who peddle these narratives
for their own gain hold on hold on a
second yeah
uh coveted lockdown shut down 15 million
small businesses a record number of
small businesses but
the big companies by the way who what
we're talking about politicians 350
million dollars just from facebook into
the election
uh whatever happened to citizens united
and getting money out of the election i
don't understand not anymore um
companies like alphabet amazon facebook
they've managed to increase their
profits billionaires have increased
their overall net worth
by half a trillion dollars wow
so when you say that they these what do
these business owners stand
to gain on a massive scale other than
again providing income and food for
their families
yeah absolutely what do you think it's
done to charity charitable giving in the
church
around the world has gotten to just fall
through the floor right and he says
he says two things right they must and
these are the things that we
have to do like there are no
alternatives oh yeah hold on a second
uh hold on uh what is it what what is
yeah
what's what hello uh we have thomas what
is it
i can hear him oh
thomas finnegan what what's going on
steven
uh can you case set me up with
get gaby yeah the gap uh you mean
gabby.com
crowder yeah yeah i'm i'm trying to to
do the
the paperwork online but uh it's asking
me for my information yeah yeah so no
yeah people who don't know their sponsor
gabby
contrast how do you go it's it's free
and actually you enter in your insurance
information
and then it shows you where you can get
a better rate because a lot of people
get locked into insurance for years and
don't realize that right
better rates elsewhere yeah okay i i
put in all my information but it's
it's not it's not giving it to me it's
not giving you what
it's not giving me the the insurance
wait yeah no you have to enter in your
insurance information to see are you
trying to get insurance right now
thomas finnegan
i won't go back okay all right let's let
thomas finnegan go wow
and uh by the way for people who don't
know that's gabby.com crowder you get a
free uh
check i was shocked that's fantastic
right
how about all it is you just go and you
check it and they don't sell out any of
your information by the way
privileged i think yeah i think i've
heard that they like customers save like
an average like nine hundred dollars
it's something written that's wild i
thought there was a mistake yeah right
it's a pretty easy product i looked i
was like really because i've been paying
insurance for a very long time and then
they don't give you the discounts
because you just get used to paying for
insurance so gabby.com because you enter
in uh
our url you will get it for uh free a
free check nice um
i believe uh now we are going to be
getting on the line here um
any second uh the mother and if i'm not
mistaken the father as well
of the bullying question for people who
don't remember uh who didn't see this
segment earlier right before we bring
them in i want to show this video again
it was making the rounds and everyone
here at ladder with crowder our blood
was boiling roll clip what do you want
for christmas
still breaks my heart to watch yeah you
don't know
what
that's a mom right there stepping in for
something nerf gun dad wants to get it
for you that's fine but i can't bring it
to you
what else would you like lots of other
toys there's legos
bicycles and the kids holding it
together is being scolded
what do you think
what do you think
now santa cares now comedy santa cares
all right we have on the line with us uh
sabella i hope i'm pronouncing that
right decarlo uh the husband
who you don't see in the video michael
de carlo who's also a police officer
uh thank you guys for being here can you
uh can you hear and see me
yes we can hi stephen hi thank you for
having me thank you for being here and i
tried to so we don't have your son he'll
be on after this but i i did go through
the whole
hair and makeup and i'm very sticky
right now uh
but i'll say our blood was boiling
watching this
uh video um your son will he's by the
way i thought he was like six or seven
because he's very tall your son is is
four
correct yeah he's four and a half he's
four and a half okay
so yeah that's that's a really rough age
to be scolded by santa and can i just
say
the composure of your son was remarkable
he stayed you know you could see him
kind of holding it in until the santa
continued was like no
no what else do you want what would you
don't tell my son it's okay
right yeah no no it's okay santa's
santa's being a chastising [ __ ]
just it's fine um what was going through
your what was going through your mind
while you were watching this dad
a police officer i've got to imagine it
would it would take everything in your
strength to not beat santa's ass and
ruin the spirit of christmas for all the
other kids there
well right well the reason why we were
video
recording it in the first place was
because mike was on the street and he
misses a lot of
michael's first so
we wanted us we wanted him to see like a
really cute exchange with santa his
first time telling him what he wants you
know
and um that obviously was not the case
but as it was happening i looked over at
my mom like is this
really happening like i was in shock and
i was almost like
nervous laughing under like yeah is this
really i i couldn't believe it and then
you know you can obviously see
the heartbreak on my son's face so
i mean i would when i i
yeah consoling him and then you know
hoping to call santa over for a little
minute
um you know for for me what's remarkable
is when i was a kid and i used to go to
mall
santa's i don't know about you but they
always used to say very general things
because they don't know the parents
budget like we'll be a good boy and
we'll see
what uh you get under the christmas tree
not you know uh have you been to
momsdemandaction.org
[Laughter]
i mean you know so i that alone was
surprising to me
what happened after the video did you
talk with santa did he uh apologize
no i couldn't even look at him i you
know i just
consoled michael wiped away his tears
and i
kind of wanted to salvage as much as i
could so we did have them take a picture
it's his sister's first christmas
it's his first year well he did visit
santa last year but
he was three and he didn't really
understand the magic wasn't as intense
as it is this year so
we continued with the picture for i
don't even know what reason
but then we just left and bought him a
bunch of stuff at the mall
well and that's also challenging too
right because you want it to be a
surprise for your kid but santa puts in
that scenario where he says i'm not
going to get you a nerf gun where you
almost have to say hey
hey hey don't worry you'll get a nerf
gun and then you also lose the surprise
of christmas so there there's a litany
of things that he did wrong
right well we told him he you know the
mall santas are just santa's helpers
right you know yeah he accept
that so well that's good that's what my
parents would tell me to and that's why
when i talk with your your son here and
i i want to make sure i have him he's
four years old i've got some information
here for
people who are watching so we can help
with the magic of christmas
um he's a boxer he loves rocky balboa
uh has a blue christmas tree in his
bedroom he has a bulldog named carlo pug
named ozzy and i have a little uh i have
a
bully breed here named joe lewis after
my favorite boxer
so i think it's providential that i get
to be
you know the real senator not the
department store santa this is this is
santa making a real call
and dad what did you think when you saw
that video like can you issue a no knock
warrant
you know i mean i my wife was called me
and told me
and uh you know first like any foul
you're furious you're livid you know
and i'm like well what'd you do it you
know she actually handled it the right
way
you know you can't you know you got to
be calm and comfort her kid
get him away from the situation and then
address it later right
which is getting proud of her you know
yeah i would hopefully handle
some way right yeah that's the one thing
it's i've got to imagine you have to
balance obviously being responsible as a
parent but being incredibly protective
and you know people talk about sort of
the the moments that you have
like graduation or you know a wedding or
obviously the birth
but these are also experiences as
parents that are unique you know the
first time where a kid is cognizant of
of santa you know the magic of christmas
and
and you guys put in a lot of work there
too and just for some
activist to tear it away and this kid
probably your son probably wants a nerf
gun because he wants to be like dad a
police officer so
i assume that he didn't the video didn't
stop and he goes to come in a mass
shooting i assume he just wanted a nerf
gun
right and inside santa shamed him for
his christmas wish you know
yeah well um i think we told you guys
unfortunately
we're gonna have okay you're gonna bring
your son and um and uh we will be
sending a cornucopia of of
nerf uh guns and if you could send us
out now nerf guns are there anything out
like does he want super soakers
i don't know what the laser tag um
what else does does the young man want
here we want to we want to give you guys
whatever we can
and label it from santa you know
i mean we're very blessed to be able to
his christmas list was fulfilled before
he even saw the santa you know
so we would love to
pass it on to other kids who really
don't
have that okay how about how about this
let's um after we finish the the program
we can get in touch with you guys
and maybe you specifically if there's
someone you can think of in
your neighborhood or maybe your church
or your community who we could help
and isn't a pink okami who hates nerf
guns
um we can help them you know we can
spread it around um
and if there is of course any i would
like to do something special for your
son as well even if it's just one small
sort of token so
that uh i can uh i can feel like i mean
yes
but you know we will graciously accept
but it's not necessary
okay well thanks so you have so your son
isn't there right now so
so you you you have purchased well he
but he can't hear you right now kenny or
you have to whisper
no okay so you have purchased because i
don't want to promise him anything here
and then he'd be like santa really it's
a dick so you
you you did get uh a nerf gun right or
some nerf guns if
i mention okay okay all right
actually this morning he asked for a
scooter and we did buy him a razor
scooter so okay all right well the
problem with those is he can turn it
upside down and it looks like a gun
um and uh and you know what i wouldn't
be surprised in a couple years if the
the kid is asking for a bb gun you know
i was talking about this earlier kids
used to ask for those a lot younger and
it wasn't
it was never considered immoral you know
the reason and
michael um you probably know this i was
talking about young boys
the reason they're interested in guns
and swiss army knives is they're
powerless everyone's bigger everyone's
stronger
and a power tool a power wheels a little
nerf gun or a bb gun
a swiss army knife makes you feel like
you can even the playing field a little
bit and my parents use it as a teaching
opportunity when i got my bb gun my dad
took me out with it and treated it like
a real firearm when i got my swiss army
knife
and they weren't looking and i was
whittling and we had a cheap swiss army
knife because we didn't have that much
so it was dull but not dull enough to
give me a paper cut non-stop
the point is my dad tried to teach me
proper respect of these powerful tools
and uh it's amazing that someone decided
to take it upon themselves but michael
you remember what that's like as a boy
you're never going to stop boys from
playing cops and robbers
oh no they still play well he
technically is a cop so he's not playing
but the nerf wars at home you know it's
it's crazy what goes on here so
yeah okay well hold on a second so
here's what i'm gonna do i want you to
bring in
uh young uh michael let me get my hat
and my glasses on
and uh uh right i have it right his name
is also michael right
yes okay and then i will talk with him
uh for a little bit i'm gonna get into
santa character
and uh and hopefully uh hit the reset
button and then after that we'll talk
with you guys later and see how we can
bless someone in your neighborhood or or
how we can work together so hold on let
me get into out let me get into uniform
it's really just a wig and the glasses
here all right hold on
oh that's small because of my giant
cranium
wow i have i have famous guy head where
it's like the camera
grows your face like a radiation from a
microwave
all right listen i've got to say uh my
mother does wardrobe and makeup here
and um i'm pretty impressed with her
thank you thompson
um i i spent about an hour in makeup for
this
so uh well listen thank you guys so much
thank you for making time on the show
and thank you for being so considerate
you know listen this is a perfect
example of checking
your privilege not because someone's
guilting you but saying hey we're
blessed enough to
be able to provide this for our kids and
maybe we can bless others see that's
what happens whether you're middle class
upper middle class whether you're
wealthy you can find a way to pass it on
and uh what a wonderful thing to do at
christmas merry christmas
all right um also you know baby jesus
certainly
yeah that's a big part of it the christ
child of course yes yes
savior to the world all right sabella
and mr dicarlo again thank you for uh
thank you for holding the lines uh there
for us too
as a police officer send in the young
boy give him the headphones and
uh santa's going to be ready to uh talk
with them
all right all right i will go get him
perfect hey buddy
michael
[Applause]
[Music]
oh there's little michael
little michael do you know who this is
making a call just for you
who is that santa this is santa that's
right
and i understand that you're a fan of me
santa and uh
you had a little bit of a run-in with
one of those uh helpers at the mall who
hadn't been vetted properly yesterday
is that right what what do you call him
um bad santa
that's right bad santa who didn't pass
the uh chemical test beforehand but
we've taken care of that and as the real
santa uh i understand that uh you know
the rules of engagement here that you've
been a very have you been a good boy
this year
okay now i know that you're uh you're a
fan of
uh of boxing just like old santa here
uh you like boxing and uh you're a big
fan of
rocky balboa do i have that right
oh maybe that's another little michael
maybe i have that wrong you're not the
boxer
that's you let me see those let me see
those fists
there young michael let me see put up
your dukes oh
look at that i think that's going to be
a heavyweight look he's in his peekaboo
stance
wow wonderful now look at that training
with custom auto so
young oh now you've been good though
right you've been good you you don't
do you know who customardo trained mike
tyson and uh
i understand you also you have two young
two dogs
right do i know one is a bulldog
and then there's another one what kind
of dog is is uh
ozzy
he's a pug oh they have to be delivered
by c-section
now do you know that santa claus you
can't
see him but i have a
i have a doggo argentino who's like a
bulldog
and his name is joe lewis
i don't know if you remember joe lewis
but he's a world famous boxer from a
long time ago
that might be before your time it's okay
now
i want to be clear young michael you're
being good with boxing though right
you're not boxing you're uh you're not
boxing any friends who don't want to
you're not being a bully right
no no okay that's good you know when you
when you get big and strong like your
dad there who's a
who's a police policeman who helps keep
us safe right now and there's some tough
times in the united states
people like your dad out there keep us
safe because they learn
how to use their firearms and their
hands to protect the innocents right
you promise santa right now that as you
get big and strong you'll only use that
to help
people right not hurt people
do you promise i need to hear you say
that michael otherwise there's going to
be
coal you promise to help people
he's joking now i'm joking i know you've
been very good this year now
let me ask you this uh young michael
what is it i know that
the helper again no association there
we're looking through hr
and i'll uh get back to your parents
about this
what was it that you asked that
unqualified
helper for uh at the mall
a nerf gun well that sounds like a
wonderful
gift a wonderful toy and that man told
you no
oh well let me tell you that's not the
that's not the
real santa he's what your parents will
teach you about when you get older he's
what we call
a communist and we
we had to get rid of them at the north
pole i don't know if you know this but
santa actually has used firearms for a
very long time and also of course
always taught and encouraged firearm
safety
did you know that during world war ii
santa claus taught people about firearm
safety and how to use guns properly
no you know santa even right here when i
travel on my sleigh up north sometimes
we get
bears or we get something you know that
could hurt santa's reindeer so
santa old saint nick packs a heater
would you like to hear the story about
the time that my piece saved my reindeer
would you like to hear the story michael
yes that's okay you don't need to be shy
santa likes to have a laugh
so i was i was at the north pole i had
to stop it what was a pic
a pit stop we have a we have a fast
charger now
i had to go back to the north pole
before going over to a far
away land that's very dangerous called
france and when i was there we had a
grizzly bear
and the grizzly bear was accompanied by
a pack of wolves
and so santa had to take his gat out
from his chest
i fired two times in the air to keep my
reindeer safe
and they ran off and no one was hurt and
blitzen was able to live another day
so see if you use firearms and your
strength properly you can protect people
and keep them from being hurt just like
your pops over there
you know what do me a favor if you want
a gift i
want to give you a gift okay i really
want to give you a gift my i think that
nerf gun sounds mighty nice
but give your mother a kiss on the cheek
and give your dad right now a big old
hug can you do that for santa
okay your mother first ladies first now
give the old
give the old policeman a big hug
oh that's wonderful oh look at that
that makes this made my
cord it made your cord go well that's
okay listen maybe
santa comes down your chimney with
something wireless
okay but you just need to keep that
behavior up
all right well listen michael i know
that you're very busy and santa's very
busy but i tell you what
maybe this christmas you might have
something special there under that blue
christmas tree in your bedroom keep that
up
make sure you put out some cookies for
santa and
some carrots for the reindeer you know
reindeer they're
they're they're herbivores right you do
that and uh be a good boy
and i think i can't make any promises
but you'll probably get just what you're
looking for this christmas okay
michael
all right and just make sure
make sure michael one more thing i'll
ask of you when you see people down the
street
be friendly show them a smile and say
merry christmas to everyone because i
know
yesterday was hard and that man was mean
to you and throughout your life you'll
find some people who are mean some
people who are mean are less happy with
themselves
than they are with you and what you do
is you continue getting big and strong
listen to your mother and daddy and you
just be nice and smile right back and
say
merry christmas to all all right michael
i have to go feed the reindeer and i
have some elves who are being
insubordinate so i have my plate full
but thank you so much for taking the
time and i look forward to stopping by
your house this christmas okay michael
thank you louder thank you oh
thank you that warms my heart bye
michael bye sabella and michael senior
thank you for taking the time
we'll talk with you a little later oh
that was wonderful
what nice people they are
dwight can i clear this all right there
we go all right that is exhausting no
wonder that commie gets surly
[Laughter]
that was very sweet oh my gosh i love
that i
never tell you the story then we have to
go we're going to go to mud club loud
slash mug club 30 off if you enter the
promo code crowder election stream
we'll be playing manny the art critic
yeah and taking your chat
but um i was oh i one time
i applied to be a santa claus by phone
oh wow okay so it was you know they
would give you kind of that information
yeah no i didn't audition like a phone
santa yes
and they would pay you by the call
interesting and i had to drive about 45
minutes away
for a drug test and i never heard back
no i don't know
i have never i had never taken drugs in
my life when i haven't even consumed a
drop of alcohol
so i don't know if being drugless
precluded me
oh that's an interesting thing that's
the only way you can handle making calls
something hallucinogenic yeah i have no
idea
but i tell you what if i didn't have to
work full-time as the bastard that i am
to make sure everyone here is still
gainfully employed
uh i would love to be a mall store santa
man
you know what here's the thing guys it
doesn't take much to make a kid happy
the kid just you know what that was when
i just say hey you have a dog hey you're
the kid just to him santa's important
and he just wants to feel listened to
he just wants to feel like he's
important and guess what you don't have
to be santa you can just be a mom or a
dad
or if you're a department store santa
just don't be a prick
just make the kid feel like he's
listened to all you have to do
is repeat what they tell you take an
interest in what matters to them
and you know what this is why we need
more dads in the house this is why kids
need a mommy a daddy and they need to be
in the house because that kid right
there i believe if not mistaken they're
in chicago his dad is a chicago police
officer
and you know what some kids there have a
rough situation in chicago
but that's two parents who care about
their kid and statistically that will do
more for him
than any school could than any
forgiveness of student loan
than any uh socialized health care you
take your pick
nothing is going to give that kid a leg
up more than a mom
and a dad and maybe a nerf gun
underneath his uh bedroom blue christmas
tree this year everyone who's been
watching
let me know too again we're just looking
for your comments um the comment squad
uh what was your most magical christmas
moment with santa claus let's talk about
that too and i don't always respond but
we do read the comments and we'll be
doing an ask me anything next week
so we'll be aggregating your comments
it's the best thing you can do just to
cut through the youtube algorithm
thank you so much right now we have to
go to keep everyone gainfully employed
another 45 minutes of show
at mug club lot of card you know the
rest youtube
you can go piss
off